prince's death must have hit you pretty
hard because you knew the guy right
really hard because
not only that i know him but i i i i
musically worshiped him a genius is
genius i i musically was when i was a
kid i would listen to his music and my
grandmother didn't understand what's
this devil meant
he's singing about [ __ ]
because a lot of songs he had a song
called [ __ ] control he's singing is he
talking about [ __ ] i said yeah and
pushing control is a great song
yeah but i remember saw hearing soft and
went for the first time i remember the
the b-sides whenever i feel like giving
up boom
boom whenever my sunshine when you hear
songs like that would you go and like
try to write a princess
and it was all horrible but you can't be
prince but but i remember when he said
in france skinny man died of a big
disease with a little name by chance his
girlfriend came across a noodle and soon
she did the same at home this 17 year
old boys and their ideal fun is being in
the game called the disciple high on
crack tone the machine gun
i mean the reason he's great is because
his lyrics first of all i can't believe
you know lyrics i cannot memorize lyrics
did you ever ask him like how do you
come up with this [ __ ] i never had that
opportunity to do that because i was so
in awe of him but when you shot with him
you were like too freaked but i would
sit with like i would talk to terry
lewis jimmy jam or i would talk to
morris day and they would just say the
kid is just a genius cause you gotta
think about this music where does music
come from
it's it's a gift it's just it's just out
there
and to be in that to be inside of him
and i i met him i met him for the first
time
december 31st
1998.
it was about to be 1999. oh it's at mgm
in las vegas and i look and i said and i
was like i was like a fan man i know
that ain't prince over there dawg god
damn and irena man you know who you is
[ __ ]
did you do one of those oh my god i said
oh my god i started kind of crying but
but that's the problem too you it's hard
to have a real conversation like that
because you kind of want to be cool and
i'm just you want to be cool all my cool
went out the window i said man i know i
started naming the albums i'm [ __ ] up
the titles and i said man you know when
you wrote this [ __ ] and if it was [ __ ]
ninety it was nineteen [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
and and and and and he was so cool and
he knew i was shook
nah well thank you so much yeah yeah
and i was like damn the [ __ ] so
cool and i remember asking for a picture
that's [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up did he tell
you no yeah he did and it was the camera
it was the disposable it was this one i
said hold on
oh i ain't got nothing in this one let
me get them oh i got more in this hey
let me get that picture he says um
i don't do those yeah
you know you're right you're right you
sh you should you know what you should
[ __ ] but i was like [ __ ]
and then that night
morris day and the time were playing for
new year's right and they were singing
cool see oh
[Music]
break it down now check this out i'ma
have my friend come out on stage but he
ain't gonna sing that [ __ ]
y'all don't ask him to sing he's just
gonna play and he came out press came
out
and just played and he had this big
little sort of like purple feathery
froth hanging
and he [ __ ] mowed him down bro